chairman
you are the chairman of the chamber
you are chairman of the chamber
you are not the careers chairman
when room here makes a request
for article under the mention of article 68
then I find it very strange
that you say as chairman of the chamber
yes,
but the cabinet
you should not demand that
you don't have to
it's just there
and I think you as president of the chamber
100,000%
must stand behind the chamber's right to information
and I request you as chairman
again yes to send me that information
that can also be individual
is also in the article
that we get that information
I also did not say at all
that is government policy
I said you want information
because it is literally quoted in the media
and I now ask you chairman
to stand in front of the room
or behind the room
you want to send this information request to the room
or to bring it to me individually
thank you so much that is indeed a new request
uh and I repeat again that uh
we cannot demand things towards a cabinet
and
in addition,
there is also no majority for your request
I do appeal to the cabinet
a question was also asked by Mrs.
Beckerman
to see what
the minister can say about this in her contribution
I think that's a distant conclusion looking at
the different reactions that have been given
I understand that it is disappointing
but there
is also a ruling of the majority of the chamber
we can't demand things
Article 860 really needs more interpretation
I'm really stopping this discussion now
no no no
we just did a point of order
that was aimed at me
we are now really moving on to the debate no
you have a new point of order
yes but that was aimed at me
it wasn't supposed to be uh no no no
we go no
it is now sufficient
and again we can listen
also what the minister can say about that later
no we go
we are not going anymore
there are different solutions
this will remain my reaction in it